well California congressman Duncan
Hunter says he will be reelected in
November after he and his wife pleaded
not guilty to 60 counts of using
campaign funds for personal expenses
the couple is charged with conspiring to
steal more than a quarter million
dollars from his campaign falsifying
spending records and ignoring multiple
warnings from staff about improper use
of campaign funds Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the latest Nancy good
morning good morning and despite those
dozens of charges the judge agreed to
set a low bail $15,000 for the
congressman $10,000 for his wife because
prosecutors said the couple is currently
living paycheck to paycheck in an
interview hunter denied some of the
purchases defended others and in some
cases appeared to blame his wife didn't
spend any money illegally a few hours
after his arraignment Republican
congressman Duncan Hunter said any
misuse of campaign funds was not his
fault my campaign did make mistakes
there was money spent on things not by
me but by the campaign he said his wife
charged alongside him handled the
finances whatever she did on that
that'll be that'll be looked at too the
indictment says both hunters used
campaign funds for seven years to pay
for groceries school tuition utilities
alcohol and dinners out three family
vacations in one year cost donors more
than $24,000 that's how we campaign and
try to raise money is my travel and
having dinners meeting people and
raising more money when hunter needed a
pair of Hawaii shorts his wife allegedly
suggested he buy them at a golf pro shop
so they could list it as a campaign
purchase of some golf balls for wounded
warriors I did not use campaign money
especially for wounded warrior stuff
there's no way hunter says he conducted
a quote objective audit before the 2016
election and paid back sixty thousand
dollars but the government alleges he
and his wife stole more than 250
thousand Republicans worried Hunter's
legal trouble creates an opening for his
Democratic challenger a Palestinian
mexican-american Democrat who had
already been out raising the incumbent
in what's normal
a reliably Republican district and I
think Washington shoot him up and spat
him out and engulfed him in the
corruption it is too late for
Republicans to replace hunter on the
ballot even if he were to step down he
has been stripped of his committee
assignments a move he initially resisted
but now Norah
he says he'll go along with it
interesting to see how that throwing the
wife under the bus strategy works Nancy
thank you